[Music]
foreign
do you want to be on the right side of
History do you despise anyone to the
right of Joseph Stalin do you love sex
and hate consent then join the
entertainment industry there is no other
profession in the world where you can
pretend to be an amazing person on
social media while sexually assaulting
women and kids this is actually very
Progressive Francis of course it is the
sex offender Community are a tiny
marginalized group that victimized
purely for their sexual preferences by
joining their entertainment industry you
get to work with like-minded individuals
and do what you do best far away from
the prying eyes of racist and oppressive
institutions like the police the courts
and rape crisis centers we urgently need
a safe space for badly behaved
celebrities
BBC for short the great thing about
these dodgy celebrities is that they
come in all shapes and sizes it's true
diversity lizzo a body positive woman of
color what does body positivity mean
she's had a positive test for type 2
diabetes anyway she recently got into
trouble for allegedly demanding that her
dancers eat bananas out of strippers
vaginas in a nightclub
bananas in vaginas does sound like a
kids TV program true and when has a
children's TV presenter ever been
accused of anything dodgy and now we
have the scandal with Russell Brand
apart from Russell and the women
involved none of us know if these
allegations are true what we do know is
that his questionable Behavior was not
challenged when he was working for the
BBC Channel 4 the guardian and in
Hollywood on the contrary when some
women did come forward with allegations
people like lbc's James O'Brien and the
Guardians Marina Hyde dismissed them out
of hand it was only when he was no
longer regularly appearing on mainstream
TV that the allegations were taken
seriously because it's important to
hashtag believe or women just not when
you're making tons of money out of
a celebrity who might be doing a bit of
wipey wipe of course everyone left and
right has got their favorite conspiracy
theory about this if you're on the right
he's being smeared because he got too
close to the truth in ignoring the fact
that these allegations have been an Open
Secret in the British comedy industry
for over a decade the time Sunday times
and channel 4 have been working on this
particular investigation for four years
Tucker Carson claimed that brand is
being persecuted because of his
criticism of Pfizer and the West support
for Ukraine ignoring the fact that
plenty of people have criticized both
without being accused of rape by
multiple women including one Tucker
Carlson and if you're on the left brand
has deliberately courted an audience of
people who distrust the mainstream media
to get away with his alleged crimes as
if there's a single person left on
planet Earth who trusts the mainstream
media he didn't create a YouTube channel
which analyzes hot button Topics in a
contrarian manner to prevent these
accusations being taken seriously if you
wanted to protect himself he would have
retired to his farm and stop saying
anything about anything the only thing
any of us know is that the allegations
against Russell Brand are incredibly
serious but until and unless he's
convicted in a court of law that's all
they are what we do know for certain is
that an industry that has created
emboldened and allowed dozens of sexual
predators to flourish might not be the
best judge durian executioner for a
character they helped to create not only
that what the media haven't told you is
that there are a number of other popular
comedians who also have a stack of
allegations against them for some reason
they haven't published those could it be
that they're just too Progressive to
expose the moral of the story is you can
definitely trust us we're not popular
and we're way too weird and unattractive
for a mainstream career YouTube and
acast have now demonetized Russell
Brand's account meaning he can no longer
earn money from his videos brand is now
publishing his content at a loss so he's
operating on the exact same business
model as the guardian but brand wasn't
demonetized because the people who own
these platforms are such good guys who
care about victims Caroline Diner who
chairs the culture media and Sport
select committee wrote to the big
platforms the morning they shut down
Brand's ability to make money from his
content now I know what you're thinking
another example of woke Lefty Council
culture except Caroline Dunwich is a
conservative allegedly even more
interesting is that Caroline dynage is
married to Mark Lancaster Mark Lancaster
was the deputy commander of the 77th
Brigade of the British army until July
2020. the 77th Brigade was responsible
for helping to quash rumors from
misinformation and counter
disinformation a direct quote now we
know what you're thinking is it possible
that stupidity is sexually transmitted
we're not saying there's a conspiracy to
silence Russell Brand nor are we saying
he's innocent or guilty we're just
saying the Caroline darnage should be
suspended from her job and demonetized
while we get to the bottom of these very
serious allegations I'm writing an email
to the government right now
[Music]